gut dann beginnen wir mit der heutigen
sitzung und ich möchte noch ein kleiner
nachtrag hier machen und zwar möchte ich
ihnen noch zeigen was ich unter dem
seehasen verbirgt also so sieht der
seehase aus ich habe das letzte mal
etwas undeutlich an die tafel gemalt das
hier ist ein seehasen das ist und wir
hatten uns jetzt gefragt ja nochmal
zusammenfassend der seehas wie sie
ziehen ist nicht sonderlich einem tier
ähnlich sieht eher aus wie eine koralle
oder so eine pflanze eine säge wächst
säge wächst aber er ist ein tier und er
ist
und der ist er hat neuronen irgendwo
hier da diesen bereich und wir hatten
uns gefragt kann ein seehase kannte
repräsentationen bilden von der abend
und wir hatten uns dann überlegt könnte
es sein dass die neuronen auf bestimmte
reize der außenwelt auf dieselbe weise
reagieren wir haben da drei neuronen
angesetzt und haben die so verändert
dass die veränderung oder die
konstellation der neuronen so genau
genommen einer einem reiz der außenwelt
entspricht dann haben uns überlegt ja
das könnte vielleicht schon der
repräsentation seien aber ein begriff
oder eine vorstellung der außenwelt ist
es irgendwie nicht und ein weiterer
wichtiger punkt war der dass wir gesehen
haben dass die irrtümlich kite also dass
der irrtum eines tieres halo hat es noch
in irgendwelchen
hatten wir gesehen dass also der irrtum
der irrtum eines tieres nichts bedeutet
nicht insofern etwas bedeutet als wir
sagen müssen das tier ist primitiv wenn
es wird sondern der irrtum ist gerade
ein zeichen dass das tier höher
entwickelt ist also irgend können nur
gescheitet tiere zum ist deswegen im
zeichen von intelligenz weil das man dem
tier wenn es sich wird eine vorstellung
oder eine repräsentation unterstellen
kann die eben nicht mit der wirklichkeit
übereinstimmt aber an der an die das
tier sich sozusagen klammert eine
annahme könnte man sagen oder eine
position im ganz schwachen sinne und die
proposition ist falsch als ein irrtum
bedeutet immer dass deine position oder
so was ähnliches vorliegt jetzt
vielleicht nicht genau das salz oder so
aber seine vorstellen oder so eine
annahme rinnen die in der
internationalität die aber letztendlich
nicht begründet ist
nein
okay das ist also wahr war das thema der
letzten sitzung dass der seehase und
jetzt hat mich eine kommilitonin
dankenswerter weise auf das neue große
buch der gartenvögel hingewiesen
mit schönen bildern was ihn sehr sehr
ans herz legen kann mit mehr als 50
arten im porträt und da steht jetzt was
interessantes drin was uns auf das
heutige thema gut vorbereitet ich
zitiere mal überhaupt ist ihr das laut
repertoire der vögel überaus vielfältig
und obwohl sehr gut untersucht sind
gewiss noch längst nicht alle
einzelheiten bekannt und verstanden
so können kohlmeisen unterschiedliche
rufe miteinander kombinieren und damit
nicht nur sehr differenzierte
informationen über ihre umwelt und sich
selbst mitteilen sondern auch
artgenossen situationsgerecht warmen
oder zu bestimmten handlungen auffordern
dass dies nicht zufällig geschieht und
die vögel aus einzelnen rufen
regelrechte setzte mit einer
festgelegten grammatik bilden konnten
wissenschaftler kürzlich durch versuche
mit japanischen kohlmeisen zeigen ob es
sich dabei um die bei uns vorkommende
art handelt deren verbreitungsgebiet bis
in den fernen osten reicht oder um eine
aufgrund bestimmter molekulargenetischer
unterschiede jetzt von manchen experten
als eigenständig angesehenen sehr nahe
verwandte kohlmeisen art ist in diesem
zusammenhang unerheblich die forscher
nahmen ruf kombination von einzel vögeln
auf die zuvor bei artgenossen eine
bestimmte komplexe reaktion ausgelöst
hatten zerlegten die rufe im labor in
die einst laute und fügten diese in
anderer reihenfolge wieder zusammen
diese spielten sie anschließend frei
lebenden kohlmeisen vor ergebnis anders
als beim technischen abspielen der
original mitteilung reagierten die vögel
nicht darauf offensichtlich verstanden
sie solcher art veränderten sätze nicht
mehr
damit konnte erstmals die experimentelle
beweis erbracht werden dass eine
einfache kann
mattick auch bei vögeln vorkommt und
dies kein alleinstellungsmerkmal des
menschen ist sagt jetzt jedenfalls der
autor was wir jetzt für uns daraus
lernen können ist offensichtlich hat der
autor oder der experimentator eine
auffassung von sprache die besagt dass
sprache eine grammatik haben muss also
dass es in der sprache nicht nur um
einzelne zeichen ankommen aufkommt
sondern dass es auf die kombination
dieser zeichen ankommt und dass
dieselben zeichen dieselben laute in
einer anderen konstellation nicht mehr
dasselbe bedeuten
und da ist jetzt diese flexibilität
genannt von der deka gesprochen hatte
magath hatte ja gesagt also um sprache
anzunehmen muss es müssen die laute sehr
flexibel kombiniert werden können
offensichtlich handelt es sich bei der
kommunikationsform der vögel um etwas
was anordnung sensitive ist kann man
sagen also hier ist eine besondere
flexibilität drin wäre jetzt zumindest
man hinweisen anzeichen darauf das wird
vielleicht so eine foto sprache vorliegt
wegen diese flexibilität
ja das als nachtrag oder vorgriff und
jetzt kommen wir zu dem text der
heutigen sitzung von jon chu pre
gespräche mit affen reflexionen über die
wissenschaftliche erforschung der
sprache und die pre
ist also ein englischer
wissenschaftsphilosophie und ich
greift ein bisschen voran und zwar
möchte ich hier habe ich ihn auch schon
mitgeteilt per e mail
sie haben ja zu beginn dieses seminares
von coco dem gorilla weibchen gehört und
das ist kürzlich im alter von 46 fast 47
jahren verstorben
das bis jetzt glauben gute bezug dazu
und in diesem text den wir heute
diskutieren werden kommt auch ein bezug
auf coco vor
jetzt lassen wir einfach mal den text
hier von diesem herrn dupré sagt
gegenwärtige versuche menschenaffen eine
form von sprache beizubringen gehen auf
die arbeiten von b&r gartner zurück
bereits früher wurde eine reihe von
versuchen unternommen domestizierten
schimpansen gesprochene sprache
beizubringen
doch sie waren durchweg erfolglos die
garten als gelangten zur einsicht dass
die misserfolge ebenso auf das fehlen
eines passenden stimmapparat bei den
affen wie auf deren mangel an sprach
eignung zurückgeführt werden können
daher versuchten sie ihren schützlingen
vor allem der schimpansin was schauer
oder wie man sie anspricht der
zweifellos bekanntesten unter den
sprechenden affen die amerikanische
gebärdensprache american sign language
einzelnen beizubringen
die garten als reklamierten einen
beträchtlichen erfolg wird dieses
projekt warschau habe ein vokabular von
gut über 100 zeichen und bedeutete
gesprächs fähigkeiten erworben seither
sind eine reihe von anderen schimpansen
sowie ein gorilla bar und ein orang-utan
in der gebärdensprache unterrichtet
worden
diese fortschritte jetzt genannt werden
haben dagegen eine ganz andere strategie
verfolgt sie versuchen schimpansen
vollkommen künstliche symbolische
systeme beizubringen
dies bedeutet dass dies in einem ersten
schritt lernen mussten metallstück in
unterschiedlichen farben und formen der
reihe nach auf eine magnettafel zulegen
um dann in einem zweiten schritt tasten
auf ein speziell gestalteten
computertastatur zu tun können
wenn sie sich jetzt mal dieses setting
anschauen am ende magnet metallstück in
unterschiedlichen farben und formen der
reihe nach auf eine magnettafel legen
inwiefern ist eine solche ein solche
versuchsanordnung sinnvoll wenn man die
sprache untersuchen möchte was was ist
der vorteil von einer solchen
versuchsanordnung hier
sehen wir auch das denken
[Musik]
die hat es also mit mit klick auf die
begriffe wäre das eine möglichkeit
überlegen sie aber nur mal die anordnung
nummer die dir eine versuchsanordnung
also es gibt klare formen die bezüge
referenzen herstellen lassen war noch
eine meldung da ja
irgendwas auszubauen
[Musik]
ich denke dass entscheidend ist dass das
diese zeichen flexibel angeordnet werden
können also man hat hier in
versuchsanordnung die das wesen der
sprache sehr gut einfängt weil sprache
wir gesehen haben etwas ist was nicht
starr funktioniert sondern dass sich
immer im zusammenhang erste gibt also je
nachdem welche reihenfolge ich vornehme
von zeichen so verändert sich auch die
sprache
wir lesen jetzt einfach mal weiter diese
forschung wird zahlreiche interessante
fragen auf ich möchte die derzeitige
diskussion in drei hauptkategorien ist
es richtig einteilen muss es heißen
zuerst möchte ich kurz betrachten was
diese verschiedenen affen wirklich zu
tun gelernt haben zweitens möchte ich im
hauptteil dieses kapitels verschiedenen
einwänden nachgehen die gegen die
behauptung erhoben wurden diese affen
hätten genuin sportliche fähigkeiten
erwerben
diese einwände verdeutlichen welcher
weise die entsprechende forschung
wichtige methodologische fragen zur
wissenschaftlich untersuchen der sprache
aufhört
schließlich möchte ich einige der
unterschiedlichen ziele und interessen
betrachten die diese forschungsprogramm
unter kritik daran zugrunde liegen also
sie haben den text der sicherlich
gelesen und am ende bringt die pre oder
in der mitte kommt die pre auf mögliche
einwände zu sprechen die gegen eine
solche annahme vorgebracht wurden
jetzt geht es um die frage was lernen
affen und jetzt kommen wir wie gesagt
auf coco und skurriler weibchen zu
sprechen
sie erinnern sich an dieses video was
wir uns angeschaut haben zu beginn des
semesters da hatte coco mit ihrer
trainerin sehr rege kommuniziert
jedenfalls hat es den anschein gemacht
und man hatte wirklich den eindruck dass
coco sich hier unterhält dass die sich
gut verstehen
die beiden
und jetzt schauen wir uns mal an was
jetzt hier geprägt
zu dieser kommunikation sagt die
behauptung dass affen wenn auch nur bis
zu einem gewissen grad eine sprache
beherrschen hat eine riesige kontroverse
ausgelöst
ein hauptpunkt in dieser kontroverse
betrifft die frage ob affen jemals
irgendwelche sin taktischen fähigkeiten
erwerben
angesichts der weiterhin geteilten idee
von noam chomsky dass das wesen der
sprachen ihren unendlichen produktiven
kräfte liegt die in der syntax wurzeln
ist dieses problem auch dahingehend
interpretiert worden dass die äußerungen
von menschen auch nicht wirklich
sprachlich sind andererseits wird in der
debatte anscheinend weitgehend
eingeräumt dass die frage was für die
syntaktische kompetenzen erforderlich
sei vollkommen ungeklärt ist ich möchte
sie hier übergehen
so jetzt nochmal chomsky kennen sie alle
enorm chomsky diesen
sprachwissenschafter diesen bekannten
linguisten amerikaner der eben sehr
bedeutende beiträge zu diesem thema
sprache geliefert hat der lebt auch noch
und wenn sie jetzt mal schauen er sagt
also dass das wesen der sprachen ihren
unendlichen produktiven kräften liegt
die in der syntax wurzeln was meint er
damit genommen
worin liegen die endlich produktiven
kräfte der sprache
worin könnten die ligen überlegen sie
mal
genau wir haben nur eine begrenzte
zeichenzahl und können damit eigentlich
unbegrenzt viel ausdrücken wer wir haben
diese flexibilität das meint er dann
auch das was die karts gesagt hat die
vernunft ist das universal organ die
vernunft ist nicht gebunden an bestimmte
vermögen bestimmte organe sanchez 1 ein
organ zweiter stufe was diese unendliche
flexibilität aufweist
je nachdem wie wir zeichen anordnen wir
konnten wir können das alphabet die
zeichen des alphabets sind ganz
verschiedene weise anordnen und je
nachdem wie wir sie anordnen ergibt sich
eine neue bedeutung daraus dass es gibt
zwar teilweise so weit dass wenn man nur
ein ein komma falsch setzt ein kleines
strich jedenfalls selbst wurde wenn man
ein apostroph setzt also das kleinste
zeichen was wir wirklich haben so ein
apostroph das dann ganz anders den
rauskommen kann wenn man nur den satz
passend genug konstruiert dass also ein
kleines zeigt ein kleines strichlein den
ganzen szene vielleicht verändern kann
im falle dieses apostroph ist es in
deutschen wenn es jetzt einwenden mit
einem es aufhört neben das positiv also
dass der genitiv mehr wird dann genitiv
draußen also es apostroph im englischen
genau so ähnlich also solche kleinen
zeichen können enormes enormen sin
ändern
und jetzt sagen eben viele menschen
affen haben nicht diese flexibilität die
diese unendliche produktive kraft die
dzemski vorauszusetzen scheint damit man
sprache ansetzen kann ziemlich klar ist
dass man offen beibringen kann ein ganz
beträchtliches repertoire von symbolen
zu verwenden
und jetzt kommt der bezug zu unserem
gorillaweibchen coco allem anschein nach
der star auf diesem gebiet coco soll
über ein vokabular von rund 150 bis 600
wörtern verfügen je nach
verfügt haben müssen wir jetzt sagen
verfügt haben je nach strenge kriterien
die angewendet werden auch wenn dies
etwas umstrittener ist kann man zudem
sagen dass affen einige dass affen
gewisse sprechakte vollziehen können
diese beiden behauptungen werden
hinreichend durch eine leistung
veranschaulicht bei der weitgehend
übereinstimmung darüber herrscht dass
affen dazu der lage sind etwas zu
verlangen
meistens zeigt sich zeigt sich in den
äußerungen die von sprach trainierten
affen berichtet werden dass sie
verschiedene nahrungsmittel und getränke
witzeleien und andere bevorzugte
vergnügen einfordern
angesichts der tatsache dass diese
forderung durch die verwendung von
wesentlich abitur und symbolen von
zeichen eine auswahl von tasten die mit
geometrischen symbolen gekennzeichnet
sind und so weiter erfolgen scheint es
klar dass diese affen symbole verwenden
können dagegen wird gelegentlich
eingewandt dass alles was dabei
geschieht ist darin besteht die affen
einer guten weise ahlers chinas kinder
ist ein anderer forscher so zu
konditionieren dass sie bestimmte
wünsche die resultate hervorbringen
diese diese ansicht nach zu den affen
von dem man sagt er gebe das zeichen
gibt mir eine banane im wesentlichen das
gleiche wenn er rate die zum drücken
eines roten stand das trainiert worden
ist um ein nahrungsquellen zu erhalten
also was steht jetzt hier einander
entgegen wenn sie jetzt dieses zitat
noch mal lesen wie welche opposition
ergibt sich jetzt hier
also ich schreibe ich eine sprache
fragezeichen gibt jetzt zwei auffassung
cocoon
coco hat die eine sprache besessen
welche zwei möglichkeiten gibt zu ziehen
also es gibt jetzt keine die davon
ausgeht dass sie es hat und eine
skeptische enthalten
hier kommt der einband hier
was spricht jetzt dafür dass coco über
sprache verfügt ja
nein
ja oder nein dafür spricht kann symbole
verwenden
ja
das spricht noch dafür gibt es noch also
die dagegen verwendung ist konditioniert
ist los also packte ist bloß ist nur
kondition
also zeichen sind abitur
damit ist gesagt die zeichen selbst
enthalten keine bedeutung
sozusagen überlassen genau also so ein
zeichen wie zum beispiel rot roter kreis
der sagt jetzt nichts pause beim apfel
zeichen sind also die bedeutung wird
selbst conti selbst konstituiert vom
verwender der zeichen knüpft sozusagen
zeichen
zeigen sind austria haben sie noch
irgendwelche pro und contra punkte
anschließend tat jetzt ja
hier haben menschen so ein schalter ist
ja an sich jetzt auch nichts was eine
bedeutung ansieht schon trägt ja genau
schalter umlegen auf den knopf drücken
das bedeutet jetzt nicht apfel oder
irgendwas haben sie sollten welche
punkte
ja dagegen würde sagen dass der mensch
zu positionieren also steht ja auch das
hinstellt ist okay
also mensch beeinflusst
versuchsergebnisse das zu lernen
es beeinflusst ergebnis also eine
selbsterfüllende prophezeiung ist und
dieser art also der mensch in dem eine
besondere besucher versuchsanordnung
voraussetzt und auf die art und weise
wie er diesen versuch leitet trägt
letztendlich dazu bald dass das
rauskommt was er eigentlich sucht
das ganze fest
minute
das auch wenn dann auch die
aufforderungen von musik geht was auch
immer passieren dass sie kaufte er immer
noch dieses zeichen mit ihren vornamen
also dass praktisch deswegen jetzt
könnte man sagen beim affen keine
konditionierung vorliegt weil eine
repräsentation vielleicht vorhanden ist
die nicht abhängig ist von
konditionierung sie bräuchten jetzt
endlich ein kriterium um konditionierung
von flexiblen zeichen verwendung zu
unterscheiden konditionierung hat was
sehr starkes schematisches die
regelhaftigkeit die eigentlich nicht
flexibilität bedeutet ja dass ein guter
punkt ja das könnte man jetzt jemals ein
kriterium ansetzen um zu schauen ob hier
wirklich jetzt so eine form von
sprachlich keiko liegt oder ob es nicht
doch eine komplexe konditionieren ist
also das ist jetzt sagen die opposition
das sind die zwei koordinaten die die
frage nach der sprache der tiere
verwenden betreffen also sind es bloß
eine komplexe konditionierung oder haben
handelt es sich hierbei um so was wie
repräsentationen und sie sagten es ja
wenig eine repräsentation von etwas habe
dann habe ich die auch wenn der reiz
nicht vorliegt oder wenn das setting
nicht mehr da ist unter umständen dann
habe ich das abgespeichert in meinem
kopf da bin ich davon nicht mehr
abhängig von irgendwelchen reizen die
mich da konditionieren
konditionierer von gegenüber
sehr gute frage herr ist eine gute frage
also ich glaube die moderne
lernforschung würde sagen dass lernen
nicht nur ein konditionierung aufgeht
sondern das lernen im wesentlichen in
kreativer umgang ist mit etwas aber ein
moment der konditionierung müsste immer
dabei sein
also ich denke die lernforschung würde
nicht die konditionierung grundsätzlich
ausschließen aber sie würde sagen darin
geht das lernen nicht auf wir müssen
erstmal reize verarbeiten information
muss auf uns eingehen wir müssen immer
wieder dieselben muster beobachtet haben
aber ich glaube das entscheidende
besteht dann darin mit diesem muster
dann flexibel umgehen zu können und in
neuen situationen zu neuen lösungen zu
kommen einfaches beispiel wäre nämlich
noch guten der grundschule sie sich
vielleicht auch noch wenn sie diktate
geschrieben haben am anfang war es so
man hat letztendlich den text gekannt
man hat sich darauf vorbereitet und
irgendwann so in der dritten vierten
klasse war das diktat dann werden wir
nicht mehr bekannt dann war das was der
lehrer die lehrerin vorgelesen hat neu
und da war dann dieser transfer
gefordert in dieser art ich kann ich
kann es auswendig klären ich kann mich
darauf vorbereiten
ich kann immer wieder dieselben
situationen in klausuren vorfinden oder
ich kann man eine neue situation
vorfinden die wir nicht gelernt haben
die wir nicht einstudiert hatten auf die
ich nicht konditioniert wurde und dann
muss ich jetzt meine auf basis von
konditionierungen erlangten fähigkeiten
kreativ einsetzen nur einsetzt ich
glaube das ist ja das entscheidende beim
lernen dass wir es auf neue situationen
anwenden können
das ist reine konditionen und das ist
die basis eines jeden sprachlichen
erwerbs aber darin geht glaube ich
sprach er nicht auf und ich glaube
sprachlich hat dann auch irgendwann mal
was damit zu tun dass wir neue sätze
bilden müssen neue verbindungen
herstellen müssen die wir so noch nicht
gelernt haben
sprache vielleicht er aber jetzt wenn es
zb mathematik geht oder so ein
mathematik das wird darauf mit kreative
lösungen kommen müssen auf den neuen
lösungsweg dem ich so noch nie gelernt
habe ich kann also dieser lösungsweg
kann mir nicht durch konditionierung
eins zu eins vermittelt worden sein
es ist ein neuer lösungswegen ich glaube
der mathematik sieht man es vor allem
sprache hat sicherlich mehr mit
konditionierungen zu tun wir jetzt meine
these als mathematik als mathematik oder
physik oder sowas
aber auch in der sprache gibt es regeln
in der sprache gibt es eine grammatik
und ich kann wenn ich diese regeln
verstanden habe auf basis dieser regeln
zu der generierung von setzen kommen die
ich als solche noch nie gehört ich kann
sätze bilden
auf basis der regeln indem ich regeln
anwenden sondern die regel anwendung
die frage ist jetzt die ob regel
anwendung eine konditionierung ist wegen
anzuwenden ist eine frau
begegnete stranzl stand
genau wenn die wenn die vokale
weggefallen sind wir können uns auf
basis von konsonanten mit dem wort bild
und als auch eine kreativität dann drin
also das ist nicht mehr nur so
konditionierung glaube aber ich würde
schon sagen konditionierung ist immer so
die grundlage auch des menschlichen
lernens ganz banal ein pauken dieses
einhämmern dass ich ein pauken
das ist die basis und dann muss aber
eine kreative flexible umgang erfolgt
also ich glaube tatsächlich dass lernen
immer so was aus beidem netz wirklich
dass beides zusammen kommen muss aber
hier ist halt die frage kommt beim tier
etwas vor was diese flexibilität habe
hat kann symbole flexibel vielleicht
noch flexibel verwenden
das ist die frage und sie sehen da
streitet sich die forschung r streitet
sich die forschung es gibt hier keine
klare eindeutige these die jetzt als
unstrittig gelten darf das ist jetzt
wirklich fraglich und jetzt gehen wir
etwas näher auf coco 1
aber er ist noch ein einwand man könnte
vielleicht erwidern dass der ratte
tatsächlich beigebracht wurden ist das
rot kügelchen bedeutet und dass sie
dadurch eine minimale semantische
kompetenz erworben hat doch im
allgemeinen richtet sich der kern der
kritik darauf dass der affe und vor
terror idee hatte nicht weiß dass ein
zeichen etwa ex banane bedeutet und
sicherlich ist man nicht geneigt dieses
wissen der ratte zuzuschreiben
wahrscheinlich weil es sparsame
erscheint der rate lediglich die kausal
überzeugung zuzuschreiben dass das
kügelchen des schalters nahrung bringt
der kritiker möchte das gleiche über den
affen seien also es geht jetzt hier
letztendlich um die frage
was wären die ratten ich mache auch mal
ein fragezeichen hin und das während die
affen noch mit fragezeichen
also affe und rate stehen jetzt für
sprache und konditionierung die kritiker
möchte das gleiche wie mit den ratten
über den affen sagen das zeichen gibt
mir eine banane zu geben ist im
wesentlichen das gleiche wie ein baum zu
schütteln damit bananen herunterfallen
wahrscheinlich sollte man nicht annehmen
die zurückweisung diese kritik erfordere
den nachweis dass affen explizit
semantisch überzeugungen hätten zum
beispiel überzeugung dass xp name
bedeutet wer schon eines derartigen
semantischen aufstiegs würde sicherlich
die meisten kleinkinder und viele
erwachsene von unserem
sprachgemeinschaften ausschließen
sätze wie banane bedeutet banane sind ja
ziemlich raffinierte bestandteile von
philosophischen spielereien
es wäre viel vernünftiger zu fordern
dass man fähig sein muss mit iks mehr zu
tun als lediglich ein verlangen zu
äußern damit als verwenden von dix als
symbol gilt allerdings beachtet man die
berühmten sprachspiele mit den steuern
zu philosophischen untersuchung
paragrafen 1 bisher also was sagt er
jetzt hier
inwiefern sind sogar manche kleinkinder
und viele erwachsene nach einem gewissen
kriterium von unseren
sprachgemeinschaften auszuschließen
was ist ihre
also geht man doch mal hier auf
tierarten hatte xxx
ex wird der name zugeordnet oder banane
wird nichts zugeordnet wie auch immer
was sagt jetzt dieser text bei den
ratten um was handelt es sich da ja
den taschen gekommen
hierdurch sind greifen müssen
gruppen gegeben
ja aber gäbe nochmal auf diese ratten
erst das ist ein wichtiger punkt aber
gehen wir erst noch mal auf die ratten
ein was was sagt denn jetzt hier dieser
text mit bezug auf diese zuordnung ickx
und banane
was ist jetzt hier wie muss dieses
verhältnis im braten paradigma gedacht
werden oder rot und kügelchen da muss
ich genauer sagen er will ja keine
banane aber jetzt bleiben wir mal bei
diesem beispiel
ja ja ja sie hatten sie noch gemeldet
seid also unseren
sally kausalität ist wichtig dass der
wichtige punkt es ist bei der ratte hier
nach diesem zitat nur causa also es geht
hier nicht um bedeutung sondern es geht
um kausalität also kausal überzeugen
der rat lediglich ist es die kausale
überzeugung zuzuschreiben dass das
drücken natürlich überzeugung ist eine
überzeugung eine proposition hat eine
überzeugende proposition aale struktur
haben ratten überzeugungen formulieren
ratten das setze oder das äquivalente
gedanken könnte man sagen
also da wo diese kausalität ins spiel
kommt da haben das nicht so sehr mit
dieser flexibilität zu
das ist nicht direkt dem ich ja es geht
in diese richtung des mechanischen
paradigmas kausalität wenn adam b a und
b also kaufe alle zuordnungen und das
müsste man jetzt unterscheiden von nicht
nur kausalen überzeugungen sondern von
bedeutungen also der unterschied ist
folgende wir müssen auf der einen seite
hier bedeutung finden die frage was
bedeutung es ist eine riesengroße sprach
philosophische und frage und in der
philosophie des geistes was ist eine
bedeutung system an tig was ist mit
bedeutung das sind gewisse vorstellungen
damit verbunden gewisse vorstellungen
bedeutung oder kausal überzeugung
das ist das ist die frage ist die
bedeutung der seebühne kausal
überzeugung also wenig tue dann passiert
das was würden sie sagen kann man
bedeutung gleichsetzen mit kausal
überzeugung
da
auch die aufbauen
nichts
sollten
ein
mg
genau als sie würden sagen kausalität
ist einfach zu schwach um bedeutung zu
konstituieren kausalität ist abhängig
eben von reizen und so eine bedeutung
würde konstituiert werden ohne einflüsse
von außen die würde mit seiner mentalen
repräsentation vielleicht verbunden
werden während hier die der status der
überzeugung abhängig ist von
fortgesetzten reizen
er wird praktisch durch reize erst
konstituiert die überzeugung würde aber
nicht mehr aufrechterhalten werden wenn
eine zeit verstrichen während dieser
reiz und da bleiben würden meint sie das
gut ja ja auch wenn diese haben zusammen
genau das führt uns jetzt eine ganz
spannende frage nämlich zu der frage wie
bedeutung überhaupt zustande kommt
da gibt es verschiedene modelle es gibt
ein modell das ist dieses kausale modell
deshalb tatsächlich bedeutung kommt
dadurch zustande dass wir etwas kaufen
also wir es gibt so ein tau fakt
letztendlich und dann wird das ganze
kausal fortgesetzt wir beziehen uns
letzten endes durch kausalketten auf das
ding das wort führt letztendlich zum
ding durch tau faktor und so weiter und
sofort lässt sich zurückführen dass eine
bedeutung oder bei wittgenstein dem
frühen wittgenstein die mit gestand des
tractatus das also letztendlich die
sprache ist ein logisches abbild der
welt ist also ein abbild verhältnis die
sprache die bedeutung die fast
letztendlich die logische struktur der
tatsachen der welt so wie sie ist zum
abbild verhältnis sprache und welt sind
in einer struktur analog und da gibt es
noch ein drittes drittes paradigma und
das ist der später wittgenstein des
wissens ist sicherlich der sagt sprache
oder bedeutung genau genommen gibt es
nur dadurch dass wir uns in einem
sprachspiel befinden dass wir also in
einer sprachgemeinschaft sind und
dadurch dass wir begriffe gebrauchen
also alles eine gebrauchs theorie der
bedeutung begriffe erhalten ihre
bedeutung nicht durch oder wörter durch
struktur analogie zur welt sondern
dadurch dass wir sie verwenden und zwar
nicht nur als individuum verwässernd
einer sprachgemeinschaft regelmäßig
verwenden als solistisches modell wieder
der sprache sprache desto als im
hintergrund wollten sie noch also
zusammen
dass man das eingehen von das rad fahren
das beben muss etwas repräsentieren sein
er spricht ja auch hier der text von
einem minimalen semantischen kompetenz
sie haben schon recht es gibt eine
gewisse bedeutung schon eine gewisse
bedeutung also eine gewisse bedeutung
gibt es weil nämlich diese
konditionierung erfolgt ist weil etwas
etwas anderes repräsentiert also diese
sven adam b repräsentiert b oder b-
repräsentiert
und da sagt der text eine minimale
minimale semantische kompetenz der rat
aber die frage ist ob das wirklich
semantik im eigentlichen sinn betrifft
ob damit wirklich bedeutung konstruiert
ist eine konditionierung
die bedeutung
abhängig irgendwann ist die bedeutungen
sich nach
gut wir sind glaube ein guter punkt es
ist abstrakt es ist nicht mehr
angewiesen auf diese reize diese
permanenten heize und dann kommt ja so
eine gebrauchs theoretische semantik ins
spiel wird dieses zeichen im kontext von
anderen zeichen konkurrent verbindet
wird es gleichmäßig verwendet wird das
einheitlich verwendet sondern mal kurz
hier weiter die kritiker möchte der
kritiker möchte ich das gleich über den
affen sagen das zeichen gibt mir eine
banane zu geben ist im wesentlichen das
gleiche wie ein baum zu schütteln damit
bananen herunterfallen
wahrscheinlich sollte man nicht annehmen
die zurückweisung diese kritik
erforderte nachweis dass affen explizit
semantische überzeugung hätten zum
beispiel besonders xp name bedeutet das
ist natürlich ein sehr sehr
anspruchsvolles kriterium dass der affe
zugleich noch rechenschaft abgeben
könnte über die verwendung dieses
zeichens das wäre dann zu viel der
reflexivität wir lesen mal weiter diese
forderung scheint in der neuen affen
sprachen forschung ziemlich weitgehend
berücksichtigt worden zu sein die
tatsache dass die fähigkeit eines affen
ein symbol auf eine besondere weise zu
verwenden nicht zur folge hat dass ihr
alle fähigkeiten besitzt die
natürlicherweise mit dem wissen von der
bedeutung eines gewöhnlichen substantiv
verbinden ist durch einige experimente
von servicerobotern gezeigt worden
beispielsweise kann affen beigebracht
werden äußerungen zu produzieren die für
das fordern von verschiedenen
verfügbaren nahrungsmitteln geeignet
sind
doch die affen gäben keinen hinweis
darauf dass sie in angemessener weise
als adressaten der gleichen äußerungen
antworten können zum beispiel indem sie
den genannten gegenstand aus einer
gruppe von gegenständen auswählen
eine ähnliche trennung von sprachliche
produktion und rezeption ist auch in der
sprachentwicklung von kindern
festgestellt worden
andererseits ist ist ebenso klar dass
dies nicht der typische fall für
trainierte affen ist den oben erwähnten
experimenten zeigten die tiere sobald
sie die fähigkeit erworben hatten
bestimmte äußerungen ebenso zu
beantworten wie es selber zu produzieren
keine schwierigkeit diese fertigkeit in
bezug auf neu erworbene zeichens fall
gemeint
viele verblüffende illustrationen für
den flexiblen zeichen gebrauch können
aus den berichten der forschungsarbeiten
von petterson gewonnen werden sie
berichten von beschreibung die ihre
gorillas von gegenwärtigen und
vergangenen ereignissen gemacht haben
sowie von witzen drohungen und
beleidigungen
ok
also hier wird jetzt gesagt sie zeigen
keine schwierigkeiten die affen
bestimmte äußern ebenso zu beantworten
wie selber zu produzieren keine
schwierigkeit diese fertigkeiten bezug
auf neu erworbene zeichen zu
verallgemeinern
hier wäre jetzt eine flexibilität
gegeben wie wir sie verlangen erfordert
fürsprache dass eine flexibilität
gegeben ist das ist also das
entscheidende
hier gibt's jetzt an an hinweise auf
einen flexiblen zeichen gebraucht hier
flexibler zeichen getroffen
das könnte ich vielleicht hier auch noch
rein im habe ich ja eigentlich schon
kann zeichen flexibel verwenden das ist
so ein punkt für die sprache
okay wir müssen also schauen wieviel
gorillas im kongo damals als sie noch
lebte wie die in welchem maße sie
flexibel umgegangen ist mit der
verwendung von zeichen das ist das
entscheidende
ob hitze drohungen und beleidigungen
wirklich vorliegen das ist natürlich
eine spannende frage
hier ist die gefahr ganz groß dass wir
einem anthroposophisch muss erliegen
das sind doch dinge die eigentlich recht
menschlich kommentiert sind und ihr
neigen ist sehr schnell dass irgend
welchen tieren menschliche
verhaltensweisen zuzuschreiben die
gerade auf so eine art linke drohungen
denke drohungen gehen noch am ehesten ja
also ist es ganz klar dass tiere
drohgebärden also zeigen
das ist bei jedem anders ein elefant
habe ich jetzt kürzlich gesehen
der stellt die ohren auseinander also
der vergrößert seine fläche der macht
sich also wichtiger ein v macht das hier
auch aus anderen gründen ist vielleicht
nicht nur drogen ist er ein balske habe
sowas aber drohungen kann man glaube ich
schon ziemlich gut im tierreich erkennen
mit witzen und beleidigung
da bin ich mir nicht zu
also ein witz wie soll denn ein tier
einen witz machen aber wir lesen uns mal
weiter wer jetzt kommt nämlich über coco
noch eine ganz interessante passage die
ich ihnen auch schon mal genannt hatte
von coco wird berichtet sie verwendete
zeichen wenn sie mit ihren puppen
spielte muss man sagen obwohl sie
anscheinend verlegen war wenn sie dabei
beobachtet wurde und diskutierte sogar
über den tod
es hat coco ja der tod ereilte jetzt ist
also das praktisch realität geworden im
urin eine ausbilderin wohin gorillas
gehen wenn sie sterben dass die frage
coco sagt angenehm lässt marin wann
gorillas sterben coco problem halt
ja
frage
gewesen im nächsten abschnitt ohne dass
solche aufzeichnungen von unterhaltung
gleich brillante dialoge oder
philosophie darstellen legen sie doch
sicher mehr als konditionierte reflexe
nahe für bedeutung ist jedoch ernsthaft
infrage gestellt worden
ich möchte jetzt die angriffe genauer
betrachten gegen die schlussfolgerung
des affen wird eine echte
sprachfähigkeit ein tag legen
vorgetragen worden sind und bleiben
jetzt nur hier bei diesen dialog frage
hat jetzt coco wirklich eine antwort
gegeben
eine bedeutung oder wie könnte man das
in frage stellen ja
einen klassischen bauen also vielleicht
einfach
genau genau also wenn ich sie recht
verstanden habe würden sie sollten
folgendes sagen die hat jetzt coco den
begriff sterben gelernt oder tot tot
sein wobei sterben ja was anderes ist ne
sterben oft vielleicht so dass die
trainerin morin oder die andere
trainerin dass die mal ein bild gezeigt
hat von einem toten gorilla und wie
sieht ein toter gorilla aus der liegt
halt irgendwo und hat die augen zu oder
dass die trainerin coco zu einem toten
affen gebracht hat oder einem anderen
toten wiesen was eben da lag und
vielleicht hat coco einfach nur gedacht
das tier schläft einfach wobei ein
begriff vom schlafen zu haben natürlich
auch ziemlich ziemlich hochstufige
begriff ist aber dass wir nun so meiden
sie das hat das also offensichtlich hier
co
wenn er jetzt die an wenn sie jetzt die
antwort gegeben hat angenehm ist heyer
heißt wahrscheinlich schlafen sagt man
ja auch zu kindern ist angenehm ja
vielleicht waren diese toten tiere die
man coco gezeigt hatte in einer haltung
die dem schlafen dem angenehm schlafen
glich wir menschen sind natürlich jetzt
sofort geneigt das jetzt so zu
interpretieren als ob jetzt hier
coco sagt ja da tanzt macht sie unsere
seele auf dem weg in das oder wie würden
sie jetzt das interpretieren wenn sie
jetzt mal coco freundlich sind wie
würden sie denn jetzt also dafür
argumentieren würden ja das ist ein
zeichen von sprache wie würden sie dann
diese drei wörter angenehmen ist heyer
interpretieren wollen sich melden
die möglichkeit bestehen
oder punktgenau wir also wir neigen dazu
eine metaphorische re also eine rede bei
coco metaphorisch zu interpretieren dass
wir sagen das sind nur mit pfeffer für
höhere geistige phänomene
dabei hat sie gucken vielleicht gar
nicht metaphorisch gemeint also könnt
ihr überhaupt metaphern fügen ist eine
spannende frage also völlig richtig wir
können diese auf diese aussage
angenehmen ist eigentlich nur dann
sinnvoll rezipieren wenn wir gucken
unterstellen dass das metaphorisch
gemeint war
also dass in die metaphorische rede war
ist er hatte von von den toten
ja
ja ist es aber nicht auch eine metapher
ist das nicht eine metapher
aber ist nicht semantisch einschlafen
von sterben doch ganz klar unterschieden
also ist entschlafen gibt es nicht
die augen sind
als folge wenn es überhaupt nicht mehr
stunden unterwegs was ich nicht weiß
genau das wäre eben ist es eine
möglichkeit und hat sie dann einen
begriff von tot
also kann sie kann sie eben dann eine
wirkliche antwort geben hat sie einen
begriff von toten
gut gut
ok dann wäre das in ihre richtung was
sie vorhin sagten es ist eben ein
besonderes schlafen
wobei man ja sagt er tot ist schlafes
bruder das ist ja also ganz nah am
schlaf dran hat es noch eine evaluation
bogen sind alle weg das ist sehr reizen
dann bringe ich nächste mal noch mal
welche mit ja schön dass so viele jetzt
in der vorletzten sitzung kommen
das tv
ja dass die frage hatten sie sich noch
gemeldet
[Musik]
ein
entweder sie
[Musik]
und als
neben
die müssen
genau also es könnte sein könnte
durchaus sein dass tiere um so abstrakte
themen das so schwierige themen wie tod
zu fragen nach dem tod beantworten zu
können wenn wir mit tavoris sein werden
müssen
das wäre eine möglichkeit problem alt ja
das ist eigentlich eine sehr klare
antwort auf die letzte folge warnt
gorillas sterben oder
heute würde ich das auch
da ist
in deutschland orientiert als das ist
nicht negativ macht
unteren ende
diese krise
die begriffe
mehr
ich weiß nicht ob ich da
wilders können natürlich auch andere art
sterben aus was halt wirklich das
richtige vorgehen bilder werden in der
welt vielleicht interessant zu wissen
auch kohl also die cola man angehen
würde
aber dann könnte er ihr besonders
kritisch sehen will ist das vielleicht
gelernte begriffe probleme alte sterben
aber den kanzler nicht mehr anwenden
probleme von alle stellen also wer die
frage wie es dann
das bescheuert ich habe ja auch
interessant zu wissen was ist los
einfach nicht die ausbildung gefragt und
dann wenn ich das mal
das sieht auch sie überhaupt die auf
und ist die frage hier ist es ist es nur
konditioniert konditioniert natürlich
nicht nur durch die konkrete
versuchsanordnung sondern auch durch die
dialog person
das wären flexibilisiert werden sie das
jedem sagen würde als wenn wir dann eben
dieselben wenn jetzt einer von uns hier
zur ko ko gegangen wäre und dieselben
zeichen gemacht hätte nach dieser
gebärdensprache die diese frage
betreffen ob coco dann genau dasselbe
guter punkt jedem der von uns hier coco
gefragt hätte geantwortet hätte
genau
genau das wäre jedenfalls die
bedingungen das ist die bedingung dass
die
da wäre dann diese kontext
unabhängigkeit gegeben das wäre dann
nicht so ein kein anzeichen dass es
nicht konditionierung ist ja gut es
würde natürlich nicht es würde
letztendlich eine gewisse kohärenz
bedeuten aber es wäre noch nicht die
antwort darauf ob jetzt dieser satz
wirklich auch wenn er immer gleich
geäußert wird denselben umständen ob der
wirklich die bedeutung hat die wir jetzt
im auf den ersten blick unterstellen
würden oder ob da nicht auch noch
irgendwie eine viel kommunikation liegen
kann aber das ist auf jeden fall ein
anzeichen dafür dass hier eine
flexibilität vorliegt die nicht abhängig
ist von den konkreten umständen
gehen sie in den nächsten bus angewiesen
mithilfe
menschen sind wir diesen angegeben ist
wirklich nur das nest
gut richtig halte dieses wohin muss
jetzt nicht heißen vielleicht in einem
über himmlische nord oder so soll wo
sterben wo ist die todes städte das
schlag todeslager oder sowas von
gorillas und dann könnte man sagen gut
ja klar ich meine ist ja bekannt ich
weiß dass im geografieunterricht zum
beispiel sind in der steinzeit oder noch
früher sind elefanten die europa
besiedelt hatten
sind die zu quellen gegangen also zu
besonderen orten also die sind nicht
überall hingegangen zu sterben sondern
die hatten ganz klare orte gibt gorilla
gibt's elefanten friedhöfe gibt es sowas
das wäre dann so ein zeichen dass also
coco dann sagt gutmann geht an einem
besonderen ort
man stirbt nicht irgendwie auf freiem
feld das soll man zieht sich zurück
so könnte man das durchaus auch sehen
aber das problem ist halt wir haben hier
nur so drei wörter und wir müssen jetzt
hier semantisch sind taktisch brücken
schlagen wir können die nicht wörtlich
nehmen wir müssen die verbinden also
jedenfalls ist es doch eine interessante
auskunft die privat sie so in diese
richtung gehen würden was wir auch sagen
würden das entspricht recht unserer
intuition jedenfalls das hatte ich ihnen
auch genannt dieses beispiel ganz am
anfang als ich ihn von coco erzählt
hatte
das steht auf wikipedia das beispiel
wird immer wieder gebracht das ist sehr
bekannt da ist coco bisher bekannt wird
dieses für dieses diesen dialog und
jetzt kommen wir zu dieser kritik an der
affen sprachen forschen also wir haben
also jetzt einige an hinweise bekommen
ich weiß noch mal zusammen dass es sich
wirklich um bedeutung uns in dieser
sprache handeln könnten es ist eine
flexible verwendung der zeichen und die
äußerung wird gegenüber verschiedenen
personen auf dieselbe weise
hervorgebracht sie sagt nicht jeder
fragenden person etwas
darin kann man schon so eine art von
repräsentation entdecken
betrachten wir die kritik die an der
forschung der sprachlichen fähigkeiten
von affen geübt wurde
so ist es hilfreich zwischen den zeichen
sprachen projekten der gartners von
weißen siemens spricht und so weiter
einerseits und den künstlichen sprachen
von primark brembo und savage euro
andererseits zu unterscheiden
grob gesprochen kann man die
erstgenannten projekt ist so auffassen
dass sie durch dass sie motiviert sind
die ebene der kommunikation mit den
problemen so hoch wie möglich probanden
so hoch wie möglich anzusetzen
dies steht im gegensatz zu den zweiten
projekten bei denen bei denen der
möglichkeit saubere und zweideutig und
gut kontrollierte daten zu gewinnen
größte bedeutung beigemessen wurde so
ist man in der ersten kategorie
um die arbeiten von petterson
exemplarisch anzuführen verblüfft über
die herstellung einer beziehung zwischen
den probanden und dem forscher über eine
längere zeit hinweg hatte sind betont
beispielsweise die art wie die
kommunikative absicht ihrer probanden
zumindest für den erfahrenen beobachter
deutlich gemacht werden kann als eine
art die eine wörtliche interpretation
von zeichenketten übersteigt neuen und
unerwarteten produktion wird besonderen
nachdruck verliehen
also es geht jetzt hier um den
unterschied zwischen zeichen sprachen
projekten und künstliche sprache
die ersten als die zeichensprache
projekte besteht darin
die kommunikation so hoch wie möglich
anzusetzen
und beim zweiten ist es eher die
eindeutigkeit kontrollierte daten zu
gewinnen
hier in diesem dieser anforderung neuen
und unerwarteten produktionen wird ein
besonderer nachdruck verliehen das ist
natürlich ein gutes kriterium weil hier
haben wir dann die flexibilität sehr
sehr gut
hätten wir diese flexibilität das sehr
sehr gut beobachten können wenn eben
etwas geäußert wird eine eine
sprachliche äußerung getätigt wird die
eben nicht im verdacht steht
konditioniert gewesen zu sein
ich glaube dass das ein sehr gutes
kriterium ist was ist das problem dieses
kriteriums neuen unerwartete produktion
worin liegt da wiederum ein problem
überlegen sie mal mit blick auf die
objektivität und antrieb um office muss
was für ein problem steckt könnte hin
bei diesen unerwarteten produktion von
sprachlichen äußerungen stecken
das ist
als es doch eigentlich sehr schön wenn
wir jetzt eine unerwartete als eine
nicht erwartete aufgrund des kontextes
nicht erwartete äußerung eines gorillas
bekommen wir rechnen nicht damit die
äußerung des ersten überraschend dann
würden wir wenn wir positiv denken oder
wenn wir also zum positiven anrichten
wollten würden wir sagen wow da ist
flexibilität im spiel
das ist nicht konditioniert kommt etwas
neues jetzt was ist das problem das deck
was könnte man dagegen aber ein
einwänden gegen so eine unerwartete
äußerung von sprachlichen gehalten
ja genau ganz genau
ganz genau dass wir eben deswegen das so
besonders finden weil wir uns weil wir
da anderen office tisch da irgendeinen
sinn reinlegen
weil wir eben ist dahin sehen wollen das
besondere das ist so ein bisschen
zweischneidig
dieses kriterium anzulegen das andere
extrem liegt bei den experimenten von
primark bei denen das mögliche verhalten
der probanden vom experimentierenden eng
begrenzt wird üblicherweise wird die
machen nur zu einer sehr eng begrenzten
anzahl von zeichen zugang gewährt
dadurch werden quantitativ auswertbare
voraussagen und eine analyse der antwort
erleichtert die der affe auf besondere
anregungen gibt in gewisser weise ist
diese schafe tomi natürlich eine
karikatur in einerseits diskutieren die
forscher die sich mit künstlicher
sprache befassen die afrika fiktiven
bindungen die sie mit ihren schützlingen
hergestellt haben beispielsweise mit
rambaud den unvorhergesehen und spontan
produktion eine beträchtliche bedeutung
bei ihren experimenten hatten die
schimpansen anscheinend einen
kontinuierlichen zugang zu einer
größeren bandbreite von zeichen als
zitieren primax experimenten wenn auch
nicht zu seinem repertoire des umfangs
wie skoda war schon zugänglich war
andererseits verwenden perthes an die
garten und andere die mit
gebärdensprachen experimentieren viel
mühe auf ziemlich streng kontrollierte
tests mit dem vokabular ihre affen
können weiterlesen
neuere philosophische ansichten zum
verhältnis von denken und sprache
verleihen der affen sprachen forschung
anscheinend ebenfalls besondere
bedeutung
im gegensatz zu descartes
die karts ansicht dass sprache ein
zuverlässiges symptom für etwas zeit das
davon aber ziemlich verschieden ist
nämlich denken jetzt kommt der andere
philosophie hatten behauptet donald
davidson dass sprache eine notwendige
bedingung für denken sei
auch wenn die argumente für oder gegen
diese position hier wiederum nicht
gründlich untersucht werden können
eröffnet die affen sprachen forschung
jedoch eine spannende perspektive auf
diese thesen wenn davidsons position
nämlich korrekt wäre dann stände bei der
kontroverse um die affen sprache nicht
nur die frage auf dem spiel
ob man auf und das sprechen beibringen
könnte sondern vielmehr ob man ihnen das
denken beibringen könnte die vorstellung
dass affen die von den gartners und
anderen trainiert wurden sich darin von
ihren wilden oder untrainierten
artgenossen unterscheiden dass nur sie
über rudimentäre stecken verfügen ist
sehr viel um klaus siedler als die
vorstellung in sei einfach eine
rudimentäre form menschlicher sprache
beigebracht wurden das zieht die annahme
von der wesentlichen gleichwertigkeit
der beiden ereignisse in zweifel
ein grund dafür besteht darin dass die
kommunikativen fähigkeiten sprach
trainierte affen ganz klar ein kontinuum
mit jenen von tieren bilden die sich
außerhalb der bildungs elite befinden
dieser punkt steht in verbindung mit
einem anderen den ich zuvor betont habe
noch nicht einmal die menschliche
sprachkommunikation ist derart nach
vollkommen verschieden von jedem bereich
nonverbaler kommunikation der einen
entscheidenden teil ihres kontext bilden
wofür argumentiert jetzt hier und das
ist ein text der zum ende dieses
aufsatzes
die auffassung dass das über die frage
bei donald der pizzen gewiesen und asyl
anzunehmen dass die trainierten machen
denken können
genau also mit könnte vielleicht sagen
es gibt mehrere möglichkeiten man könnte
sagen untrainierte affen können genau so
denken wie trainierte affen nur können
trainierte affen ihr denken eben
besonders ausdrücken also eine
sprachliche form bringen das wäre die
frage an sie ist es notwendig um denken
zu können auch sprechen zu können
also wäre es möglich in ihren augen zu
denken ohne zu sprechen
ich glaube es ist so wenn wir sprechen
können dann können wir auch denken also
sprechen schließt denken mit ein
aber schließt also aber impliziert zu
denken dass wir notwendigerweise gleich
also auch sprechen müssen können wir
denken ohne sprechen haben das ist die
frage was würden sie sagen
wer ist dafür wäre ist der meinung dass
wir denken können ohne sprechen zu
können
wer es dagegen ja nehmen wir mal die
gegenargumente wenn sie wollen was ist
irgendwie okay sie würden alte sagen
sprache ist immer begrifflich verfasst
und denken ist auch begrifflich verfasst
und wenn ich denken kann dann liegt die
sprache auf der zunge sozusagen oder
liegt mit die sprache schon irgendwie
habe ich die sprache schon irgendwie
realisiert ich habe meine gedanken
sprache wäre dann das argument
sagen dass wir das besprechen können
muss aber als welchen traum von spar
dass das muss eben nicht die unsere
menschliche sprache sein
ja aber die frage war wer jetzt ja die
könnten könnte man affen denken und
darstellen auch wenn sie eben keine
sprachliche kommunikation aufweisen
zu unserer einander in ihrem vokabular
das ist das andere
ich denken kann
okay ich bin ja jetzt auch für gäste zum
beispiel
assoziativ sie würden assoziativ sie
sind wie eine spannende frage wie man
denken auffassen muss ich mein das
argument der beiden kommilitonen war
wenn ich es recht verstanden hat dass es
nicht doch immer schon begrifflich ist
denken und sprach es auch begrifflich
insofern gibt es struktur analogie und
es ist kein weiter schritt vom dingen
zusprachen
oder denken jetzt vielleicht in form von
sprache könnte man sich sagen jetzt
sagen sie dagegen nein denken ist ein
assoziatives verhelfen phänomen was
nicht unbedingt begrifflich ablaufen
muss das hat was von intuition
vielleicht fantasie ist ja auch denken
letztendlich fantasie ist nicht nur
streng begrifflich oder streng logisch
oder semantisch sind taktisch
grammatikalisch strukturiert und
trotzdem würden sie sagen ist es denken
ja würde ich sagen ja
in die hosentasche lang um der schlüssel
zu finden
und da würde man kann auch sagen das ist
denken aber eben ein niederschwelliges
denken und das wäre nicht begrifflich
strengen sinne verfasst hatten sie sich
gewöhnt
ich denke dass sprache
für irgendwas weil man erstens die
gedacht
über eigene gedanken machen müssen
ja
genau gerade bei so sehr komplexen
phänomenen wird es ganz schwierig da zu
vermitteln also sprachlich zu vermitteln
wenn wir keine begriffe haben also wenn
wir hätten dann eben in assoziativen
gedächtnis ein sehr subjektives denken
und die frage wäre die ob denken nicht
immer objektiv sein muss das ist jetzt
eine spannende frage müssen wir nicht
definitiv gerne es gibt einige argumente
die sagen dafür sprechen dafür
denken ist immer proportional verfasst
das ist so ein engerer begriff des
denkens würde sagen denken gedanken sind
pro positionen und meine gedanken das
ist gestört und hier habe ich p1 p2 p3
und ich kommen eben auf diese
verschiedenen kompositionen auf
verschiedene wege aber die proportionen
sind letztendlich aber so dass setzte
seine überzeugungen meinungen und sofort
die letztendlich irgendwelche positionen
sind das sind jetzt gedanken könnte man
dagegen spricht etwas was er intuitiv
assoziativ ist weil sich daran auch die
frage gestellt ob intuition nicht auch
professionelle strukturen haben die sie
zu fassen lassen zählt
wir sehen
das war das kommilitonen diese
kampfsportart oder genau was eine
kampfsportart sowas dass man jetzt hier
der körper in der bewegung in das
interagieren weiß der körper was er
jetzt tun muss auch oder vielleicht
besser der leib wäre vielleicht die
bessere bezeichnung richtig
wichtig dann ist es schon zu spät genau
wer denkt hat schon verloren
wobei ich noch die ist die
unterscheidung eben gerne einführen
würde zwischen körper und leid werden
sie damit einverstanden da haben sie da
probleme gegen diese unterscheidung
begrifflicher art wenn man sagt ja
häufig körper ist so das ist ein körper
den tisch und der leib ist eben der in
bewegung der beseelte körper und ich
glaube einem körper könnte man es schwer
eine sprache zu stehen aber im leib
glaube ich sehr wohl bleibt der
antizipieren kann im leib der aufnäher
reagiert wenn mir jetzt der dazu nahe
kommt dann kommt da so ein reflex der
aber nicht nur konditioniert ist und der
angepasst ist auf die ganze situation
und mit erinnerungen ein kalkulierend
agiert
immer gut an
aber würden sieht es da noch denken
nennen oder nicht mehr
meditieren denn wenn sie sagen keine
gedanken geistige betätigung würden zu
sein als ein denken ohne gedanken
proposition aller art könnte man sagen
dass man denken weiter fasst ja
nach
als sie sind
sie würden also dass so ein grad welles'
verhältnis plädieren also nicht strikt
qualitative schichten sondern würde
sagen es lässt sich einfach steigern
komplexitätsgrad steigern
sicherlich
sicherlich ja das ist auch noch eine
spannende dimension dass sprache eben
nicht eins zu eins konvertiert werden
kann sind dass jede sprache ihre eigene
realität auch hat das leuchtet mir ist
ja eigentlich glaube auch dass da was
dran ist dass jede sprache eben facetten
der wirklichkeit manche facetten der
realität besser aufpassen kann oder
schärfer stellt als es eine andere
sprache die dafür wiederum ihre
schwerpunkte setzt ja
man sollte das rad
richtig richtig gut kennen sie diesen
chandors brief an hugo von hofmannsthal
also aus der literaturwissenschaft es
ist gerade dieses problem der sprach
krise das ist eine kultur
kulturwissenschaftliches phänomen und
die jahrhundertwende also von acht von
19 jahrhundert aus 20 jahren um 1900
herum
da haben viele dichter gemerkt ihre
sprache kann eigentlich begrifflich gar
nicht mehr die welt fassen sie brauchen
jetzt andere darstellungsmodi und aus
dieser problematik der begrifflichen des
begrifflichen zugangs zur welt der eben
als begriff gewisse feinheiten immer
außen vor lässt und jetzt endlich immer
nur allgemeines begriff ist ja immer
allgemeine strukturen auf das konkrete
anwendet und damit die welt irgendwie
auch in so ein zwangskorsett zwingt aus
dieser problematik hat sich die ganze
moderne sprachphilosophie entwickelt
also ludwig wittgenstein zum beispiel
kommt ja aus wie ein wien geboren und in
wien gab es wie sie ja alle wissen sehr
viele dichter und literaten und die
haben eben diese sprach krise
aufgegriffen und mit gestern hat seine
sprachphilosophie aus diese
literarischen problematik heraus
entwickelt
warum muss es einfach so und integriert
aber
das sagen
ja ich würde sagen bilder denken bilder
so was die bilder denken kann ja ok sie
würden sagen denken ist eine abfolge von
assoziationen von bildern von
repräsentationen hier und die
repräsentation müssten nicht und die
repräsentation müssten nicht begrifflich
verfasst sein
ja ja
diese sprache
ja es gibt ja das phänomen dieser
assoziation oder die synästhesie der
dass man also farbsehen kann oder farb-
hören kann kandinsky kennen sie den
maler kandinsky da hängt ja hier im
lenbachhaus
der hat das sehr sehr häufig getan er
hatte also gibt es ein bild wo ein
klavierkonzert wie gesehen hat hat ein
klavierkonzert gesehen als das gehört
hat und er hat er bestimmte farbe kommt
hier eine trompete und das ist dann so
eine farbton und hier diese form und so
also das ist natürlich eine form von
denken die jetzt nicht begrifflich
verfasst ist ja also spannende frage wie
wir lesen jetzt noch zu ende ist es sind
gleich durch bescheidener erscheint auf
den ersten blick der vorschlag von peter
keller saß er meint das denken der tiere
können nicht bewusst seien weil sie
keine sprache hätten
ich sage dass er auf den ersten blick
bescheidener ist denn diese anregung ist
faktisch eine partielle wiederbelebung
des absurden der absurden katalanischen
these dass nicht menschliche lebewesen
überhaupt kein bewusstsein haben die
belegung die im vorherigen abschnitt
gegen die verbindung von sprache zur
verteidigung der kommunikationspartner
mensch was ist ihr angeführt wurden sind
hier anscheinend in gleichem maße
angebracht eine betrachtung von caritas
beweggründen für diese neo katalanische
oder vielleicht besser neuropathie
asiatische doktrin muss an einem anderen
ort stattfinden zwei diskussion wirft
allerdings ein weiteres wichtiges
problem aus und fragen nach dem
bewusstsein der tiere sind weit davon
entfernt einfach nur eine abstruse
philosophische debatte in gang zu
bringen sie sind unmittelbar relevant
für eine ethische problematik die in
jüngster zeit zu recht in den
vordergrund der philosophischen debatte
gerückt ist hat eine reihe von den kann
vor allem die ethische legitimität der
primera abscheulichen behandlung von
tieren in tierfabriken und in der
wissenschaftlichen forschung in frage
gestellt von freizeitbeschäftigung wie
jahren ganz zu schweigen
das sagt natürlich deswegen hier die
priwaller aus england kommt wir jagen
viele prominente ist auf grundlage der
erwähnten these überhaupt kellers dass
diese praktiken nicht nur zulässig sind
insofern sie den menschlichen
wohlergehen dienst sondern sogar geboten
wie ich hoffentlich deutlich gemacht
habe denke ich zwar nicht dass das
moralische abstoßende an diesen
schlussfolgerungen irgendeiner weise vom
erfolg oder misserfolg der tier sprachen
projekte abhängt dennoch stellen diese
projekte nützliche rhetorischen munition
bereit wenn man nicht die absurde
meinung vertritt dass es zulässig oder
geboten ist jedes tier aus einem
gebildeten affen zu quälen muss ein
verteidigender verteidigerposition
caritas die apartheid in bezug auf die
menschliche kommunikation verteidigen
eine meinung der zufolge die affen
sprache auf der tier seite des grabens
liegt ich hoffe dass ich zumindest
einige hindernisse für diese strategie
aufgezeigt haben also hier kommt jetzt
ein wichtiger aspekt ins spiel denn wir
noch nicht so häufig in diesem seminar
behandelt hatten nämlich das verhältnis
von normativität von moral und dem
ganzen tiere also wenn jetzt tiere
tatsächlich über sprache verfügen
sollten folgt dann irgendetwas daraus
dass wir sie anders behandeln sollten
oder dass wir sie nicht in einer
bestimmten art und weise sollte man kann
sie das gleich zu denken wenn tiere über
zukunft bewusstsein verfügen ist es
natürlich klar dass sie besonders leiden
wenn man sie einsperrt oder wenn sie
ihren tod antizipieren müssen das ist
natürlich dann vom leidensdruck extrem
letzter punkt die einflussreichste
sprach auffassung die bei der
verteidigung der thesen von der
radikalen diskontinuität also
unterschieden haid gemeinhin in anspruch
genommen wird ist die von james key in
der sprache als ein einzigartige
menschliches kognitives organ
dargestellt
doch selbst wenn sich diese ansicht
irgendwie als wahr herausstellen sollte
scheint dies für das hier zu
diskutierende problem irrelevantes sein
denn das problem betrifft er die dinge
die menschen tun können nicht die organe
die sich vielleicht verwenden um solche
dinge zu tun
ich gehe davon aus dass die einzigen
ernsthaften kandidaten für fähigkeiten
mit denen menschen durch einen
sprachorgan
einzigartige weise ausgestattet werden
können kommunikation und denken sind
aber es gibt viele arten nicht
sprachlichen verhaltens die
kommunikation ermöglicht und viele nicht
sprachliche manifestation von denken
wenn man argumentiert die existenz eines
speziellen sprachorgan zeige dass nur
menschen denken oder kommunizieren
könnte gliche dies der argumentation
dass nur fische schwimmen können weil
nur sie auf einzigartige weise mit
schwimm blasen ausgestattet interessante
these also er ist jetzt auch seine der
denken ein bisschen weiter fasst denke
eben nicht nur ein sprachliche
manifestation bindet und sand gegen die
these von james key und descartes
letztendlich auch argumentiert dass es
hier um ein besonderes vermögen geht er
ist er so ein freund dieser kontinuität
des zwischenmenschlichen und
nichtmenschlichen kommunikationsformen
ja in der nächsten sitzung letzte satz
noch hier von ihm so glaube ich zu guter
letzt nicht dass die forschung zur
sprachfähigkeit von affen bei allem
charme den sie zeitlos hat uns uns über
uns selbst oder über affen viel sagen
kann was wir nicht ebenso gut auf vielen
anderen wegen lernen könnten sie bietet
uns jedoch die gelegenheit zu einer
fülle von interessanten beobachtung in
bezug auf die reaktion und annahmen
derjenigen die sich in diese forschungs
begibt gebiet betätigen oder das
kritisieren und vielleicht ist ja auch
charme eine nicht vollkommen zu
vernachlässigende wissenschaftliche tun
also er ist hier so ein bisschen wir
gegen die kt sische auffassung und hat
einen sehr weiten begriff andenken von
sprachliche kommunikation entscheidend
nochmal zusammenfassend ist wohl das was
hier flexibel zeichen verwendet werden
und das kriterium von sprache kann man
sehr gut leben durch lose
konditionierung und causales denken
abheben da wo diese starre kausalität
keine rolle spielt wo flexibilität des
spieles da denke ich haben wir durchaus
anhaltspunkte von sowas wie sprache
auszugehen
ja in der nächsten sitzung die ja die
letzte sitzung des semesters sein wird
denke ich werde ich aus zwei texten
was bringen ich denke wir sollten von
john searle was lesen das ist ein ganz
bekannter philosophie des geistes und
vielleicht werde ich auch noch was von
james key hinzunehmen das werden wir
noch sehen
notieren sie sich bitte noch fragen die
sie gerne in die diskussion einbringen
wollen weil wir eben einen sechsten und
letzten sitzung auch so eine
abschlussdiskussion stattfinden lassen
wollen dann bis zur nächsten sitzung